[Music]
fear is a tool
when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
it's a warning hey what's up i'm carlos
bustamante dc's big virtual fan event dc
fandom took place this weekend and they
were not messing around when it came to
giving the fans what they want which of
course included a whole lot of batman
now before all that happened they gave
us our best looks yet at many of their
other highly anticipated movies starting
with the biggest star on the planet
dwayne johnson gave us an in-progress
peek at black adam showcasing what he
says are some early moments in the film
where his frankly badass scary anti-hero
absolutely demolishes some poor guy most
electrifying man in show business
indeed now i'm actually really excited
to see how pierce brosnan's dr fate and
the rest of the justice society fit into
this story almost as excited as i am for
the eventual black adam shazam showdown
i mean it's gotta happen right if we get
some kind of end credits cameo from
zachary levi on this one or maybe vice
versa between johnson and shazam fury
the gods one can only hope the shazam
sequel isn't coming out until 2023 but
fandom showed us some behind the scenes
footage with helen mirren and lucy liu
as well as the whole shazam family so
who knows if there's room for the rock
in there too there was also behind the
scenes footage and a lot of concept art
for aquaman in the lost kingdom with
jason momoa patrick wilson yaya
abdulmatine ii and amber heard all back
on board for what director james juan
promises will be like nothing the fans
have seen before
the featurette also gave us another
great look at that new blue stealth suit
with the uh you know the molded abs i'm
sure help with hydrodynamics it's
it's just good science
michael keaton has been speaking quite a
lot lately about his experience getting
back into the bat suit for his return as
batman in the flash and dare i say
hearing his voice covering the teaser
and seeing those pointy bad ears was my
biggest ear to ear fandom moment
actually actually scratch that seeing
the shape of the 1989 batmobile under
that tarp made me actually jump out of
my seat i was like a little kid again it
was awesome
needless to say people are very excited
about the multiple batman in this we
also have multiple flashes here too with
all the time travel and the nods to the
flashpoint paradox it'll be interesting
to see where they take the story
gotta admit though
i'm not really feeling that new flash
suit i don't know it's that's gonna have
to grow on me finally the dc movie
trailer that arguably had the biggest
impact was the trailer for the batman
what's black
and blue
and dead
i love so much about this batman looks
ruthless and unhinged everything has a
hard edge to it batman and catwoman
dynamic look solid and i love that new
muscle car style batmobile now if i have
like one like one little issue and truly
we're not going on a lot here is that
that bat suit is
very bulletproof i don't know it's not a
huge deal for me but i prefer when
batman's not you know
invincible then again it's still too
early to know for sure what's going on
in that footage the batman isn't out
until march of next year what dc movie
are you most excited about and feel free
to let us know your fan theories about
what's going on in those stories
obviously there was a lot more showing
at fandom this weekend including tv
shows video games and of course comics
so let us know what were your favorite
dc fandom moments as well thanks for
watching everyone we'll see you next
time
you